[Música]
y
cómo
a pesar de lo mucho que hemos cambiado
como sociedad la voz es todavía hoy el
principal modo de comunicación entre las
personas nuestra voz es una herramienta
muy versátil que nos permite transmitir
mucha información y no sólo a través del
significado de las palabras que decimos
sino también en cómo las decimos el tono
de voz la intensidad a la velocidad nos
permiten añadir elementos de
expresividad al mensaje que estamos
transmitiendo la voz es además un
potente instrumento musical con el que
expresarnos artísticamente la voz se
genera cuando el aire sale impulsado de
los pulmones y atravesar nuestra laringe
hace vibrar las cuerdas vocales que en
realidad son los pliegues que se abren y
se cierran a una velocidad que puede ir
de 60 a 1000 veces por segundo en el
caso de una soprano durante la fonación
esta onda acústica atraviesa luego
nuestro trato vocal que dependiendo de
su forma y disposición
la posición de la lengua la apertura de
la boca nos permite generar los
diferentes sonidos vocales este sonido
lo podemos capturar mediante un
micrófono y convertirlo a una señal
eléctrica o digital lo que nos permite
luego almacenarla transformarla
visualizarla y luego reproducirla
mediante un altavoz convertida otra vez
en sonido pero qué pasa si queremos
crear una voz que no ha salido nunca de
una boca humana las voces y artificiales
no intentan imitar la fisiología humana
sino lo que intentan es conseguir crear
una señal lo más similar posible a una
grabación real es decir no estamos
imitando el aparato fonador sino lo que
hacemos es intentar reconstruir la onda
acústica que este aparato está
produciendo
y la pregunta que podemos hacernos es
tiene sentido expresarnos como humanos a
través de una voz artificial junto a un
equipo de investigadores llevamos años
trabajando el caso de la voz cantada
intentando desarrollar tecnologías que
nos permitan generar una voz artificial
cantada con todas las posibilidades de
expresión musical os voy a poner un
ejemplo donde a partir de una partitura
podemos crear esta canción
[Música]
o sea que te
pero no vas a vivir
otros
ahora os podéis imaginar un compositor
de ópera que está componiendo su obra en
su casa y es pudiendo escuchar sus ideas
musicales cantadas por una soprano o por
la voz de un castrato virtual o nos
podemos imaginar revivir la voz de un
actor famoso para generar diálogos de
una nueva película o porque no de un
nuevo videojuego interactivo o tener
vuestra propia voz artificial que
responda por vosotros a llamadas
telefónicas o generar una voz artificial
que pueda doblar contenidos en otros
idiomas para crear voces artificiales
los métodos usados se basan en lo que
llamamos aprendizaje automático estos
métodos
lo que hacen es analizar mucha cantidad
de datos debidamente anotados en nuestro
caso nuestros datos son las grabaciones
de voz de una persona y el texto que los
acompaña estos algoritmos lo que buscan
es identificar patrones en las
características acústicas de estos de
estas señales
es decir en estas grabaciones según si
es una pregunta la entonación
de un modo terminando la frase subiendo
la entonación estos son características
acústicas que estos métodos pueden
pueden aprender además como las
grabaciones y las características
acústicas en estas grabaciones provienen
de una persona concreto podemos generar
una voz artificial de una persona
concretamente y si queremos añadir
emociones lo que necesitamos
serán grabaciones con distintas
emociones con lo que podemos generar
luego distintas emociones artificiales
os voy a poner un ejemplo de una
educación normal en modo neutro
y ahora la misma voz con un poco más
enfadada
saint louis entonces
podemos crear una voz artificial de
cualquier persona pues la respuesta es
que sí si tenemos suficientes datos es
decir en nuestro caso si tenemos
suficientes grabaciones de una persona
seremos capaces de crear una voz
artificial
actualmente los métodos que estamos
utilizando necesitan alrededor de una
hora de grabación como mínimo hasta las
decenas de horas en el mejor de los
casos si queremos conseguir una voz
artificial con la máxima expresividad
pero los investigadores alrededor del
mundo están investigando sistemas con
los que a partir de pocos minutos de
grabación de una persona poder crearía
una voz artificial estos nuevos métodos
lo que hacen es agregar grabaciones de
centenares de personas distintas creando
un mapa de voces con gran detalle y
luego con pocos minutos de grabación de
una sola persona ya nos podemos
aprovechar de este mapa de voces con
detalle para crear una nueva voz
artificial nosotros hemos creado
distintas voces artificiales con nuestro
equipo aquí tenéis el dibujo de una
cantante virtual maika con la que los
usuarios pueden crear nuevas canciones o
participamos también una campaña de
publicidad donde los fans de la oreja de
van gogh
podían componer letras que era cantada
encima de la música del grupo pero para
ver las posibilidades expresivas de una
voz artificial lo mejor es que escuchéis
un ejemplo de un experimento que
realizamos cogimos la voz de tres
oradores que no son especialmente buenos
cantantes y les hicimos cantar una
canción desde cero es decir una canción
que ellos nunca grabaron
cuando yo vamos fuisteis
it's my time
cuando cante
no
no no
[Música]
e
next
sí
no
[Música]
a ver
o
saiz
escalando
amiga
[Música]
para ser detectado
sí
[Música]
como como hemos visto en este ejemplo
las voces artificiales junto a los
últimos avances en inteligencia
artificial nos pone encima de la mesa
debates éticos sobre la autenticidad y
privacidad en la sociedad del futuro la
duda es si queremos superar la
reticencia a sintetizar algo tan íntimo
y personal como la voz o realmente nos
aterra esa posibilidad de no saber
distinguir algo real de algo de lo que
no es real pero además también es muy
importante aprovecharnos de las
posibilidades creativas de las nuevas
tecnologías para crear nuevas formas
culturales que en realidad es lo que
hemos estado haciendo desde los inicios
de la humanidad y ya para terminar os
dejo con una pregunta irías a un
concierto de un holograma de david bowie
presentando su nuevo álbum creado con
una voz artificial
nos vemos allí muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]